oh unanimous gonna go to Patty then  yeah I totally oh wow there's no way you  'd like that you got a beat you gotta  either knock them out or choke them out  my man Patty you can't have a closer I  want Pat this is gonna be a great speech  too slow down with this kid let him get  his bearings underneath he has all the  Superstar qualities do that they did  with sugar until they toss them with  Peter yawn but now they're even pulling  back with Peter Young I'm sorry with  sugar because you know he's not getting  the title shot now I thought he lost it  first the takedown I thought he lost the  first he seems totally fine  you could see two and three I thought  the third with the takedown at the end  gave to the other guy but  look at him with his arm around Joe